welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in the Bloodshed of trillions was
witnessed in a single moment a genocide
by the hands of King the Conqueror and
Ant-Man and the wasp's quantumania war
crimes witnessed by Janet Van Dyne the
moment she touched his neurokinetic Tech
and peeked inside his mind Janet
witnessed not just the horrified
objective truth of what Kang did but
even worse the memories and guilt that
he carries with him over what he did the
buried emotional subtext to every
sociopathic moment he shared with her
over their years together it is
literally 15 seconds of screen time but
it is the scariest 15 seconds of the
film and since I believe in exposure
therapy I will now break down these 15
awful seconds frame by frame because
there are some hidden visual details in
here that no one is talking about by the
way you can subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive with even more important
analyzes of the titles you love and it
could support this growing Network by
grabbing some merch and nerd writing
shot like someone from our deep dive
collection this hoodie that I call the
Thunderman is super warm and awesome
okay so these 15 seconds come up right
in the middle of quantumania when Janet
reveals to Hope and hang her history
with Kang in the quantum realm and when
she helped him repair his multiversal
engine core and she says his ship was
neurokinetic connected to his thoughts
when I touched it I saw his mind then a
close-up of Kang's eyes and Flash we're
in a field of exploding planets now the
planets don't appear to be orbiting
anything or to be part of any plausible
solar system or belt so we'll come back
to these but one planet in particular
looks like it has had a gunshot blast
through it there's a blue glowing wound
that festers on the planet's Crest with
a smoldering red core in the whole of it
and then back to Janet who appears to be
in a trance as she narrates I felt what
he had done and then there's a quick
shot of K with his eyes glowing the
lines on his face glowing a helmet over
his head as he blasts a beam from his
fist and aims it at fleeing victims in a
smoky burnt Forest as if a volcano had
just erupted these victims include some
civilization of people wearing green
clothes and a mother with her baby
remember this Kang who crash landed in
the quantum realm was wearing the same
kind of green apparel which means that
this Society was his home people the
families this Kang had spent some time
with before betraying them and burning
them out of time this tells us one of
two things either a this King started
his Conquest as a member of this society
and when he decided to begin his war
path to destroy all timelines that
threatened the Multiverse with
incursions he started with his own
people or B this gang would migrate from
civilization to civilization from
timeline to timeline like that traveling
Vagabond Victor timely or more
realistically like a serial
killer assimilated into each Society
gained their trust while he learned
about them in their timeline's
relationship with the Multiverse and
then one day snapped and massacred them
both options equally terrifying here we
see Kang screaming as he admits a
Shockwave that wipes out every tree
every Rock every person in the vicinity
blue fire throws some guys off their
feet and one screaming fella suffers
fire burning through his face his eyes
his cheeks his teeth until he becomes
fully Ash it it's not too dissimilar to
the moments Kang blasts people in the
quantum realm in the final battle their
bodies vaporizing Janet's narration
continues entire worlds entire timelines
gone like they never even existed now
things get really messed up because
those planets we saw before completely
explode not just on their own now we see
giant blue beams surging into their
surfaces from above like death star
Focus beams from this solar system we
zoom out to see these planets are
contained within a single strand of a
sacred timeline a strand that bursts
leaving severed blunt ends as sections
glowing the same teal blue snake through
those strands causing these disruptions
like Sparks burning through a gunpowder
fuse the last thing we see is a huge
bundle of strands all exploding in a
flash of white but hey can I level for a
second with you about March the month is
gross it's not winter it's not spring
it's just gray and wet it's really a
perfect month for not leaving the house
which is just one of the many reasons
why I use factor to get my meals shipped
to to me and yes in other videos you'll
hear me talk about doing the same thing
with hellofresh but factor is now owned
by hellofresh I use both and it makes my
life so much easier Factor not only lets
me skip the trip to the grocery store
but I also get to skip chopping prepping
and cleaning up
Factor meals are fresh never Frozen and
ready in two minutes so all you have to
do is just heat and enjoy Factor has 34
weekly options so I never get tired of
what I'm eating plus if you ever want to
switch things up or just pad out the
snack selection in your pantry Factor
has an assortment of over 36 quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons each meal is prepared by chefs
and approved by dietitians so you know
you'll feel good about what you're
eating no matter what your diet calls
for Factor has keto calorie smart vegan
vegetarian and Protein Plus meals on the
menu each week this month one of the
things I got was this like sun-dried
tomato chicken with chopped up broccoli
on the side it was so amazing yeah
my city on before I bit into it because
I knew how damn good it would be
that's actually really good to get some
easy delicious meals of your own just
head to factor75.com or click the link
below and use the code rockstars50 to
get 50 off your first Factor box once
more that's factor75.com and use the
code rockstars50 to get 50 off your
first Factor box the connection between
the sacred timeline and the planets here
may remind you of the black hole imagery
we saw in the opening shot of Loki
episode 6. that showed us the
relationship between the MCU Cosmos and
the sacred timeline and how each
Universe which contains all of its
galaxies its solar systems its planets
each Universe corresponds to one sacred
timeline ring but these planets in this
shot in quantumania all being grouped
together doesn't make any astronomical
sense does it so how do these planets
get here well Kang must have
repositioned these planets out of their
orbits pruning entire planets from their
timelines the time and the place they
were supposed to be to this spatial void
where they could be destroyed by
incursions he basically snatched these
planets out of their dimensional sink
and put them in front of a firing squad
now in the scene Janet continues to hold
on to the tech as we see her wide-eyed
and the sounds of Screams echo in the
distance until it all stops this goes on
for another 17 seconds so basically take
everything we just saw and double it
double A now later in the movie King
asks what she saw and he describes what
he did in a general overview destroying
timelines to stop incursions from
destroying the Multiverse yada yada but
he does not go into detail of who he was
killing in the precise method of doing
it it wasn't just the Eraser of
histories dun dun dun it was personal
betrayal where he got his hands dirty
the vaporization of families that he
knew in a Rick and Morty style
relocation of plants to another place
meaning the astronauts that were in
orbit of those planets are dead now too
and not so these planets can show me
what you got but so these planets could
both experience and be witness of
planet-wide extermination because those
planets were so close to each other you
know that they were visible within the
atmospheres of each other as each of
those plants got stabbed through their
cores by branches of death as if
trillions of voices screamed out to
Terror and was suddenly silenced but not
silenced in Kang's mind and now not in
Janet's mind either the fact that Janet
witnessed this not from some historical
archive but from Kang's own mind tells
us that he thinks about this all the
time now why doesn't Janet seem to have
this fear when Hank found her in the
quantum realm in the 2018 film and in
that movie's post credit scene when she
seems worry-free as she helps Scott
return to the quantum realm to harvest
Quantum healing particles well I think
it's because the Janet of the 2018 film
did not have that experience with Kang
because history had not been changed to
that yet the Kings as a whole would not
have been Unleashed throughout history
until the events of endgame the Time
Heist Loki's escape with the Tesseract
that Loki variant l1130s experience with
the TVA and with Sylvie and Sylvie
stabbing he remains 2-3 the Kang Dynasty
one of whom was Kang the Conqueror who
now in this revised timeline spent those
years with Janet and so Janet begins
quantumania having woken up one day with
intense fears of her time in the quantum
realm and a war criminal she met down
there memories that for her point of
view she now had always had so what did
Janet see Kang do not just wipe out
trillions of people Janet would have
little grasp of that and what that means
it's impossible to really think about
what even a trillion of anything is the
icbn that she got stuck in the quantum
Realm by stopping was only going to kill
by Hank's own words thousands of lives
so what really shook Janet is that Kang
started by doing this to people he knew
and nothing is scarier than realizing
your longtime companion sitting right
beside you is capable of that kind of
betrayal hey a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and he can
support us by grabbing something from
the deep dive collection on nerd
riot.shop you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
thank you
[Music]